still we have this idea like before the
Big Bang that there was nothing but I
actually think was the other way around
I think it was everything and then the
Big Bang is the beginning of for very
particular things I think the purpose of
this whole thing is surprise it's sort
of like a beam that could make anything
Desai's what I would be cool if I could
make something that can make something
then surprise me I think it's likely
that we will specie eight I think is for
certainly we're gonna make and that's
thousands of different species of a eyes
you know whether this kind of walking
barefoot in the woods and being knowing
how to plant a seed and have a turning
to a plant is that one of those
qualities that we absolutely don't ever
want to let go of I don't know maybe
maybe not wow we have a moral obligation
to make new technologies to make new
opportunities so that every person born
would have at least the chance to have
their gene this shy and shared well how
did you wake up many different paths and
I think that's the answer
know someone's opinion me contradict
yours what is my friend Alan it's all
about your perspective who are we and
what is the nature of this reality
[Music]
what's up everyone welcome to simulation
I'm your host Don sockin we are on site
in the beautiful Pacifica California we
are now going to be talking about what's
next and much more we have Kevin Kelly
joining us on the show hi Kevin it was
great to have you here thanks so much
for coming on the program what a
beautiful day it is it is and you have
quite the background that is paragraphs
long so I'll give the short clip of it
Kevin Kelley is an expert on macro
trends of civilization and technology he
co-founded Wired magazine in 1993 has
written multiple New York Times and Wall
Street Journal best-selling books is on
the board at the long now foundation and
much much more you can find the links in
the bio below kk org also his Twitter
profile find all his books as well all
right Kevin we have been spending a lot
of time on trying to understand the
ultimate nature of reality
mm-hmm and I would like to hear what
your thoughts are about that so we're
gonna start big yeah and then get bigger
what's always the small stuff and they
work up the nature of reality well the
honest truth is that I and the rest of
humans have no idea I mean really we
have no idea we have theories we have
metaphors that we use but we just don't
know and it's very clear even from the
terminology where we have what we know
what we know says that 95% of physical
stuff is unknown it's dark matter and
97% of all the other intangibles is dark
energy which means that we have no idea
about really what the basis is I but
nonetheless we have theories we have we
have suspicions we have hunches we have
metaphors mostly and I think for me one
of the most promising metaphors with the
promising frameworks to try to
understand things is to assume that the
fundamental reality of anything physical
things that would hurt our toe if we
dropped it are going to be very
intangible very much dematerialized very
much informational if not spiritual so
there is a famous physicists wheeler who
says it's our bits anything as it is
actually made of bits and so I think the
next big step and us trying to
understand the basis of reality will be
coming to kind of an informational based
view of both like things like physics
and the rest the world that will kind of
come to interpret through this notion
that everything real is really made up
of nothing made up of bits made up of
some kind of immaterial thing and that's
a suspicion more than I could roll out
evidence for but you know if we look at
the sub particles and set particles and
set particles and at some point it seems
likely to me that there's going to be
something intangible at the bottom
that'll be close to our ideas what we
think about information so so so I am
biased to the idea that then I'm
underlying basis of reality is
informational but I would be able to
prove that and I think the evidence for
it is very circumstantial but that's my
hunch
does it feel like we are all one well so
the answer the question is your hands
yes it does and in a very logical sense
there is only one life on this planet
I mean there literally is only one life
there's a the first cell the very first
cell divided into two cells with the
same life in it and those two cells
divided in two and we are all just
descendants of that same dividing cell
that unbroken line of I mean literally a
literally unbroken life of that division
there's not a single gap between us and
that original one okay
and so we are descendants and so yes at
one level in a very real sense wheat
there's only one life when humans say
that we sometimes talk about kind of if
something high or not just life but
other levels of consciousness and even
that that's remains to be seen I
I think that I think that the again
reflecting kind of what we know about
physics I think the amount of what we
know is growing exponentially but the
amount of what we don't know is even
growing faster and that's because in in
in science most of what you get in
science is answers but you get two new
questions for every answer so so
ignorant is actually expanding faster
than our knowledge and so you could say
in a certain sense
the main product of science is an
expansion of ignorance and as you know
with two exponential curves the
difference is exponential so we are
actually increasing ignorance
exponentially and so having said that
it's true that our knowledge
expanding tremendously fast but there is
so much that we don't know that you have
to be I don't know so much some level of
vanity to kind of state anything with
certainty I believe I think you know the
whole point of science is that it's
provisional truth and when we don't know
so much of the fundamental nature of the
universe that it's hard to rely on
something that you're worth dying for
in any any aspect and you know we when
our own lives are busy and we informed
and educated I'm a science groupie geeky
guy but even I have to have a kind of
belief in atoms I believe in atoms
mostly because people who know a lot
more about it
have told me that they really exist
right I mean it's like I I mean I could
do some kind of experiments that might
kind of suggests strongly thig is this
but I understand them as an atom you
know there's an atom actually gonna add
them right here and as these that is for
me really something that I have taken on
because other people who know a lot more
about it have convinced me enough of
them and that and that that idea fits
into everything else we know and so so
for me science is really this Web it's a
constructed web of consensus and that
for something to be added to it it has
to be added to as to make sense when all
the parts are already exist so when you
add something new to science and that
has to not only kind of match that
adjacent area has to match everything
that we already know it's a big it's a
big step and that's why sometimes we're
slow to kind of bring something into the
arena of what we know as science because
it actually has to kind of match
everything we know
and one of the reasons why you can have
these islands of knowlet's like semantic
knowledge well there's there's the
things about there's semantic knowledge
and some other ways of knowing things
they can actually be consistent among
themselves and within that body of
knowledge but the problem is is that
it's not intersecting with all the other
things that we know and so it doesn't
mean that they're wrong it just means
that we cannot bring them into science
because they just don't match with
everything else that we know and I like
to think about you know there's a kind
of a mmm there's a statement that's not
true when we talk about the discovery of
the gorilla happening and you know
eighteen hundreds or something because
it's very clear that humans knew about
gorillas way before them but there was
something true about the fact that even
though there was rumors of gorillas and
these monster men and stuff in the
1800's the gorillas knowledge was
brought into science it was fitted that
knowledge which had been local and very
parochial was brought into the whole
scientific row and it was connected to
everything else we knew about animals in
the natural world and so in that sense
it was discovered but was just being
discovered by science meaning that it
had to fit in to everything else that we
already knew and so so you know are we
one I think is a question that we're
gonna be asking for a long time and I
think they're gonna meet you know
there's many ways to answer it but but
but I think the answer it fundamentally
is this one of those things that we
don't know and will take a long time I
suspect the that the other way to answer
that is that we're going to also have
this decision ahead of us is not just
like are we lack of one mind of one
thing but this
have a real decision as a society is
whether we want to remain as one species
or not okay so so so as we go forward
we're taking on where we're going to
self-direct our own evolution your own
genetics and there will be plenty of
pressure printing of interest in
modifying ourselves and there will also
be plenty of people and I know some of
them who will say neither I nor any of
my descendants will ever manipulate
intentionally manipulate our genes even
for the so-called better and that would
lead to some very good prospect that
there might be a forking and once you do
one fork schisms are just in the cards
and so until the prospect is is that we
you know unless there is also just a
general consensus that there shall not
be that division that we won't allow it
which will mean basically that we're
going to prohibit that engineering but
outside of that this very likely that we
would begin to see multiple varieties of
our being and at the same time maybe
even in our minds how we how we think so
I I make a bit little 4x4 quadrant of
possible futures and the question is is
um or we have one species are many
species and one mind or many minds and
so you can imagine a world in which we
remain one common species with many
minds that's sort of what we have right
now we have one species with many
individual minds we could be many
species with many individual minds but
as we look forward we could also be one
species where all our minds are joined
in a kind of telepathic super organism
kind of we're all being connected so we
have one species and when mind or we
could even have many kind of species in
one mind where we're connected to all
the machines and everything else and
that so we have various and we all have
one mind so I'll hit the ball back now
yeah I love the breath I love them
Polymathic worldview generalist
worldview uh-huh I'm so deeply that
lights a fire under my spirit deeply so
to hit the ball back here you're ending
on something that many call collective
consciousness mmm this happens oneness
right so within this many times we'll
get to this part of the in the
conversation as well where we talk about
this this edge of civilizations and
knowledge being pushed yet it's also so
interesting that this idea of the
ultimate nature of reality can also be
right here as we look here me like right
here as we look in each other's eyes in
deeply and feel mm-hmm and if we
practice that mm-hmm over and over and
over yeah all right something so
profound that's beyond words right
occurs sure and so it's here sure this
nature of reality is equally here as it
is where it's pushing the edge of
civilizations knowledge where you gave
this idea of we push an edge in one of
these fields and then immediately we
learn our
is so much greater mm-hm and also
another aspect of what you were
mentioning is going back in this
evolutionary process to the beginnings
of life the genesis of life on this
planet we can go back even further to
the genesis of what is postulated as a
Big Bang or what many all creation or
source is or God or whatever people want
to call it that that is one and we are
all descendants of that right yes yes
yes and so then is it then that our
ignorance of that our feelings of
separation from that oneness from that
deep interconnectedness mm-hmm with this
oxygen that we inhale that comes from
phytoplankton and trees there's
scientific ways to discuss the
interconnectedness as well mm-hmm is
that the most root the most upstream
issue is the lack of understanding of
that interconnectedness of that unity of
feelings of separation I would agree
with everything you said it the question
you were saying is it the most important
upstream issue that I don't know what
would what could be up there as well
then upstream issue do you mean sort of
what is blocking us from progress or is
that what you mean or I'm not sure even
maybe what you mean by upstream issue
mmm-hmm what do you mean by that
mmm-hmm so we mentioned this a little
bit ago as well that when we look deeply
sure and we feel that the nature of
reality seems to also arise even simply
here okay so then there's something here
that is not practiced enough by us
enough for what enough for feelings of
understanding the nature of reality and
so again
feelings of understanding the nature of
interconnectedness of oneness is that
the most upstream issue that were not in
bed I don't know what I mean by upstream
issue this is what I'm saying what I
mean by upstream issue meaning that as a
collective to hone our attention on that
could be the most impactful for
cascading the greatest symbiosis and
flourish moving forward I took a
question I I maybe have my M my tendency
is not to believe that there's a single
roadblock or a particularly large
problem that is sort of if we solve that
problem I think we have a network a
holes collection of problems that are
all intertwined and that's certainly
part of it and I think being able to
overcome that would help but I don't
think that is sort of like it's
something that stands alone by itself my
map of reality is is that these things
are all deeply interconnected and that
that issue of understanding deeply the
interconnected oneness or unity of the
world and people while essential and
important is not alone it's what are the
other ones up there as root or upstream
issues for you
yeah so it's uh you know it's like all
these things that have to happen at once
I was just reading about the axial age
and and whether that was a actually the
idea of the actual age was about a
thousand BC there was around the globe
all these societies who kind of at the
same time in history decided to under to
position to see themselves as and to
think about the transcendent and to kind
of invent these modern religions of one
of the fix religions or even kind of the
Buddhist where you had you you you kind
of had this transcendence and that and I
think it's no coincidence that that came
along with the you know the invention of
civilization and it was her and it was
it was because we had a certain level of
prosperity that allowed us to think
about those kinds of things
alright and so and so what one of the
things that it's necessary for us to
continue progress in the development of
our humanity and making us better humans
is you know the the basic having enough
food shelter water for everybody in the
world I mean it's it's it's very hard to
it's very hard to progress in
enlightenment when you were hungry and I
think the idea that somehow starving
people or more spiritual is this
completely wrong I mean there is there
is a sense of sort of fasting and
asceticism can commune you with the
diviner when it's voluntary yes yes when
you elect what when you have enough
resources to do that deliberately yeah
but when you are dragged into it when
it's not your choice when it is
something that is stunned in desperation
there is a sense that which you are kind
of closer to the present but only in the
animal way hmm
okay and people have moments of
transcendence you know as they're dying
or whatever but that's not what we're
talking about we're talking about how to
make us better at our best and I think
it requires a certain amount of we'll
call it leisure or a certain amount of
progress or a certain amount of Liberty
a certain amount of things basic needs
being met exactly for us to be the best
that we are and so part of this gateway
is not just until you know we want to we
want to have those opportunities spread
out around the world and we want to have
more people who are not hungry every day
would you say to unleash the full inner
artist absolutely right and so now the
question is well what's blocking that
and yeah I mean at some point the the
understanding that you know war stupid
and you know fighting but all those
things are actually propelled by the
lack of resources the lack of
opportunity and so it's a the these
issues are tightly wound to each other
and that's why I don't really want to
separate them and say the well it's if
we just had understanding about the
oneness of our own life go on that does
help but that's not the only thing
so these but you asked what other ones
that so I think these issues of of
opportunity basic basic progress things
like literacy the other kind of
literacies we're just talking about
scientific literacy numeracy issues of
you know the spread of of opportunity
and the of true opportunity around the
world in in that diverse way right so
the liberation of women half of the sky
you know being brought into this those
things I think are part of that answer
and so you know in this campaign in our
quest to become better however we wanted
to find it and that's interesting
question
I think it's a multi-front effort and
and and I think there's there's many
things and there list and we kind of
have to do them all at once that's the
weird thing
I like the ones that you picked around
literacy around spiritual scientific
literacy also around the basic needs
being met for everyone to unleashed a
full inner artist right I really love
those right so you know I have a little
rant which I will do right now talking
about the role of Technology in this and
so I like to have this thought
experiment where we could imagine a
genius artist Aztec Mozart being born
2,000 years before he was mm-hmm same
person same genes everything being born
2,000 years before he was and he would
have been you know maybe a farmer maybe
I heard her and his genius would have
completely wasted because there was no
symphony there was no piano for his
genius just walking around being a
herder maybe played a flute
you know nicely but and so he would have
died and and and that moment would have
gone but we we invented the technologies
of the piano and this and the symphony
and so he was born into and so his
genius could just flourish his art
Street was just and it could share and
it was great for the world and great for
him well you know we could imagine Lucas
you know Hitchcock being born before the
technologies of cinema and what a waste
that would have been if they had been
born before those technologies and so
Shakespeare being born after writing was
invented so I say that there's a
Shakespeare the Mozart born somewhere in
the world today and she's waiting for us
to invent the technology for her genius
that she could be shared and that
therefore we have an a moral obligation
to expand those possibilities to
increase new technologies and to make
sure that the basic other necessities of
food clean water is available to all
those on the planet and those unborn and
so we have a moral obligation to make
new technologies to make new
opportunities so that every person born
would have at least the chance to have
their genius shine and shared yes I will
enjoy speaking with you hopefully in a
little bit about the actual design of
that social fabric that enables the
inner artists to be fully Unleashed
around the world I would like to also
ask does it feel like this reality is
perfect this when you say this you mean
the one that we're in right now or the
one that I'm talking about does it feel
that everything is perfect no it's
perfect I don't believe in perfect I'm
not a utopian by any means I think
perfect is way overrated
why because it's dead one of my
definitions of God is sort of like you
know perfection that keeps getting
better which is sort of
you know it's like what oh that's weird
thing so I think most perfect means that
it can't get any better well then it's
like dead it's its dorm it's static is
this reality a perfect balance of good
and evil a perfect ascension that we're
all experiencing through conscience I
doubt it
I doubt it now you know it's sort of
like it might be I mean I I think like
if you take this idea in your question
is this idea that there are alternative
universes with different arrangements of
things I think every one of the if that
is if there is a small T verse with many
different arrangements every one of them
will have a different trade-off you know
and a different character and a
different thing and so there may be some
universes where things are really key
but there can't be any mangoes that
can't be so it's like who wants to go
there is the sum of all of the
multiverse is that perfect I doubt it I
have another question what would be the
purpose of this reality being made this
I mean again this what we're in right
now our reality of everything of all
that is why is this yeah yeah yes well
you know that's been the $64,000
question from the very beginning people
ask you know why something versus
nothing and again what's the Telos sure
sure sure
the the the general the the the general
kind of intuition particularly when we
look at the scientific view of the Big
Bang is that the origin of all this
stuff there's something if it goes back
and back to this moment that kind of
before the moment even though there was
no before they for because time is
there's no time so we can't really talk
about before the Big Bang because there
was no there was no before that before
but still we have this idea like before
the Big Bang that there was nothing but
I actually think was the other way
around I think it was everything and
then the Big Bang is the beginning of a
very particular things it's nothing
including nothing that there was there
was kind of nothing space and then there
was these very particular things they
can have all the possible everything
everything meaning literally literally
all possible possibilities and so I
think the purpose of this whole thing is
surprise I think the I think there's a
being that was self made a self made
being and the purpose of this embodiment
of that that self-made meaning is
surprise mmm so it's like to make
something that this omniscient self
created thing could do that was gonna
surprise itself and we're here to
surprise God mmm
and so you know it's sort of like a
being that could make anything Desai's
well I would be cool if I could make
something that could make something then
surprise me
okay we get that that's what we're gonna
be doing ourselves we're gonna be making
robots and stuff and they're gonna we're
gonna give them creativity and they're
gonna surprise us yes yes this one's a
fun one that this being made in for the
process of becoming more alive
understanding itself better but being
creative
the symphony but expressing itself
artistically it's one of the favorites
that we love discussing mm-hmm all right
I would like to ask another theme and
this is one that leads us somewhat into
the architecting of the social fabric to
maximize the artistic expressions it
also leads us into the projects that
though even the long now foundation is
doing with the Rosetta project there is
an ethnographic condensation that is
happening on the plan and out of the
7,000 languages about half of them are
not being taught so we're very quickly
most people learning English Mandarin we
have Arabic we have Hindi we have
Spanish we have these languages most the
most common ones and then we have these
principles of what feels like in many
ways of many of these languages that are
not being passed on that have a deep
sense of interconnectedness with one
another and with their environment
symbiotically in let's take the
best-case scenario of an immediate
return hunter-gatherer style is it
principles like that that our that are
in the sense missing in modernity in
these math
of Metropolis and the that what are the
principles like principles like which
which which ones and just repeat that
last question yes yes principles like
deep interconnectedness with each other
and with the environment okay things
like the children being able to actually
see the galaxies in the universe yes
like the Apple not just being a sheet of
paper for the Apple but rather actually
observing the process of the seed the
tree right that process right right and
and and the question is is like are we
losing something vital if we lose those
in the that kind of one modernity and
may we potentially design architect our
social fabric of that future that takes
some of these principles and really
challenges modernity with wanting to
architect include inclusively of those
principles yeah so so so I I think my
guess is that the more rounded a person
is that better that person will be a
human and there is certainly there
certainly going to I don't think human
nature is static or sacred I think it is
very malleable and part of what we're
gonna be doing is changing our very
nature we're not the same people that
walked out of Africa million years ago
we have we have changed so there are
there are there are things that we have
already left behind and that is in the
nature of evolution
at the same time since we don't know
where we're going we want to retain as
many different varieties and approaches
and understandings as we can because who
knows what we're gonna need and we don't
even know what it's actually vital so I
think I think just I think it's is we
can be conservative by conserving some
things as we go along other things I
think we can give up and and we don't
know what those are and I think we
should pay attention to that and we
should be very deliberate about it but
I'm not I'm not gonna be sorry if we
leave some things behind some some
choices that's that is in the nature of
evolution is you can't hold on to all
the options you have to surrender some
of them you want to maximize when you
want to keep as many as going as
possible you always want to be able to
don't want to burn your bridges but
you're gonna have to at some point leave
something behind and so so I think we
should do that kind of deliberately if
with care with awareness with constant
testing to make sure that whatever
original human instincts or that we are
going to you know jettison that we're
pretty sure about that and so you know
whenever you a person in their life they
make a decision you know you always want
to kind of keep those options open but
if you move away and go there you were
going to leave some things behind and
that's the nature of growth that's the
nature of loving you can't hold on to
all of them so yes whether it you know
whether this kind of walking barefoot in
the woods and being knowing how to plant
a seed and have a turn into a plant is
that one of those qualities that we
absolutely don't ever want to let go of
I don't know
maybe maybe not Wow it's Wow it's
certainly I think you know I think the
person who is the roundest who is the
most who can access the most number or a
variety of understandings is probably
the better person mm-hmm but there's
just gonna be a limit to what one person
can do the more world views and states
of consciousness that one person can
abstractly reason simultaneously or have
in their catalog but then that is what
is this roundedness right it's gorgeous
when it's theirs right yeah so so so we
will I mean again you know I'm not
talking about my lifetime but you know
if we take the really long view in view
a thousand years into the future there
may be humans who literally spend no
time of their life in nature that I can
imagine that that seems that seems very
possible to me there's already that
happening inside of the boxes in the
high rises and to Thomas did yes and so
there may be other ways for us to even
to to meet some of those human desires
and that and and this is my prediction
it's because I think the technology that
we are producing will become so
complicated at some point that it will
resemble resemble natural organic life
in its complexity and that you know we
might we had may have self-replicating
devices in a thousand years may have
self-replicating devices that are on
their own gathering energy from the Sun
and replicating and spreading and that
that complexity of the Technium mmm-hmm
at that point may resemble the
complexity of
for the ganic world and so there were
people who will be attuned to that
Technium and they may get some of their
they may have no contact or very little
contact with the biological world but
they may have a lot of contact with this
complicated technique and that may may
feed some of their desire for complexity
so I so I don't I don't I think we are
malleable enough that we are going to
change what we consider human nature and
yeah for some people that's very very
scary because it is kind of like playing
God and and for others is scary just
simply because they they Revere this mix
of qualities that we have right now even
though they're not perfect and you know
and others it scares them simply because
they don't trust ourselves to to do this
well and that's that's a fair thing to
be worried about but because it could
backfire you could make some choices you
can't we you know can't fix so but I'm
I'm a little bit more optimistic in part
because I think that this is going to
happen a lot slower than you know the
rakers wells of the world believe I'm
very dismissive of the singularity idea
that this is all going to take place
very rapidly I think this is a very very
slow thing and that if we are
open-minded and if we really test and
examine ourselves we will have time to
evaluate to you know the first people
who live without nature to look at their
lives and see if they're being better
humans and so we will have we will have
time
to experiment on ourselves
leave it Kevin Kelly to take something
like the principle of planting a seed
and harvesting the apple from the tree
to be like in the Technium there will
probably be people that don't know that
aren't which even today we have people
that live in Metropolis is that don't
know that so very very interesting and
then another point to continue on this
as we go through this process of getting
into a Technium mmm that we will be
architects of the social fabric that
enables the full unleashing of the
artists in the sims yes yes and so in
terms of the design of that fabric there
are many things at play right now you
spoke earlier of the speciation of
humans mm-hmm mm-hmm
and we've been speaking about this quite
a bit these in many ways there you could
view it as a bifurcation already or
trifurcation in some ways there are
approximately this number half of the
people that make less than $3 a day
u.s. dollars in day on the planet yeah
which is less than a cup of coffee at
your shop and then there's people that
are struggling to cover their you know
roof over their head so there's those
people in the middle that have water and
that half food and have electricity but
struggle with rent and a car payment or
whatever right so there's like some
middle ground errs and then there's the
extreme errs with the private jets the
yachts the tons of cars buying up real
estate like a game of Monopoly and the
metropolis is like dropping for 20th
designer cloak per pieces of clothing
meanwhile walking past the people that
are suffering that's not one those are
not my brothers and sisters so there are
these already speciation x' that are
all right already in the fabric and then
we see certain things like we look at
trees and we look at the way they
sequester carbon and the way then they
distribute the excess carbon the large
ones to the seedlings and the smaller
ones that don't get so much through the
roots and fungal networks and do we see
that right now with our these
bifurcation try formation of inequality
that's occurring we don't really see too
much of that and the architecting of the
social fabric towards a similar of maybe
biomimic process could include something
like a an inclusive steak holding and
inclusive fitness between that oneness
where it is in our best interest to help
unleash the inner artists and that we
earn stakes in that process and that
it's already happening everywhere around
us where we use all these products and
services and fuel the shareholder wealth
of those organizations without ever
owning any sort of tokens in that in
that process yeah how do you see that
social fabric given all of those
variables just described being able to
be architected to handle such a Technium
yeah I think I think we're in the early
days of architecting you know our
society you know the amnesia about the
past is really shocking we you know my
you know the the journey from the days
of say my grandfather growing up without
electricity and
you know running water or anything - -
my life was that's that's assist an
amazing jump okay and that's that's
almost within touching distance and even
even my own I mean I have some have
troubles conveying to my own children
the parochial nature of growing up in
the 50s in a in America how really
different it was and non cosmopolitan
and and very very isolated and there's
so many things and like you know again
this desert of information about how to
do anything which we it's really hard
for them to mmm to understand like I was
telling my son to that you know we
didn't have the computers growing up and
he was thinking but but how did you how
did you get to the internet even have
computers it was like good question
you know it's like and so what I'm
trying to say about that is is is is
that we are right now I mean the the
until now people's conception of who
they were what this is all about what
they're doing with the purpose of life
and was not really about engineering
society I mean there that was there was
there was none on the agenda
there may be a couple people who were
thinking about a few people who made it
thought about that but but but this the
this idea that we that we have some
individual responsibility to be working
on this that this is the grand work
ahead of us then that we are in some
ways not just concerned about this
person in our town but this person who
lives in Ethiopia and this person that
we don't know if we was walking on the
street ever see that we are that we have
any duty or obligation or anything to do
with that that
is new and so I think the the great
frontier ahead of us is us developing
tools of collaboration of being able to
work together at the scale that we've
never been done before the scale of a
planet we have had no planetary
awareness no no global framework before
this moment this is I mean the the best
someone who might have done is become a
nationalist right if they were thinking
big but we're now required to think
globally and and and and it's very hard
because we don't even have the
information globally and so and so we
are in the process of becoming aware
that this is something we have to do to
making this society and then developing
the tools that will allow us to
collaborate at distance in real time to
do these things to spread this is
opportunities to manage all the
innumerable incredible problems then it
will curate because we are going to
create whole new global problems as we
try to do this all right I mean I'm I'm
not a utopian the each of these new
steps is gonna create new problems that
we have not foreseen and can't even
comprehend and so and they're gonna seem
impossible and people gonna wring your
hands and say stop stop stop because of
these problems but no no we're just
gonna solve those problems with other
new technologies and new opportunities
and so and so I think I don't think we
know how we're gonna construct that
society that would allow the unleashing
of all the inner artists everybody but
that is what we can work on and we can
work on the tools we can work on the
social technology like how do we vote
better I mean literally the little act
of voting can be improved
you know there's this idea is a
quadratic voting and there's there's
just we're just at the beginning of how
we do this and we haven't made much
progress because simply has not been on
the agenda and now a sort of forefront
it's like well you know when we're
connected to everybody else that's
really good we wanted that we need that
but then there's all these problems that
happens when you were connected to one
another and so all the time and so how
do we solve that I don't know but we're
gonna that they are solvable and when we
solve them that solution will create a
whole bunch of new problems and then the
answer to that is not to stop that but
to solve those problems with new
technologies it will make new problems
and so that's proto Pia that's not
utopia that's proto Pia that's progress
is incremental slow by slow will make
this out it'll be a little bit better
not by much but a little bit better and
that creep that incremental improvement
is what evolution does it's what
civilization does is interesting here
you mention that this phenomenon of
global or planetary architecting is
recent in maybe a couple centuries and
well it's I would say it's recently even
within the last 15 years decades so it
wasn't it was not possible before it was
simply you know even the the picture of
the whole earth came from Stuart brand
his campaign you know an Apollo it was I
can tell then the image of it was it was
even hard to just to have it but what's
the image of this sort of thing floating
the middle space
it's like ah there's no outside there's
nothing it's all we're all one and that
that's sort of where you could begin to
even just to have that framework of like
well we've got it you know and and all
the climate change stuff it's a global
system has to be treated globally and
there's no you can't have a national
solution to it and so it's a very very
recent awareness and within what you
were describing around this all of these
new technologies that are being
developed for the ability to manage that
architecting which is the numbers are
always staggering around ninety percent
of all new data being made in just the
last two years then at least now we're
gonna have the augmented reality
technology just to do that real time
process but you speak a lot about also
the digital twins which are very
interesting making a digital twin of
Kevin Kelly's body deploying some sort
of a solution meanwhile monitoring his
biometric state and then trying to see
if that solution was actually 50 yeah
Java T but then also digital tune of the
whole planet right there's all of these
very interesting we haven't even
mentioned quantum computing or genetic
engineering or neural interfacing there
is all of these other what uh with what
cryptocurrency is has been doing to
money um so there's all these different
things that are happening and there's
gonna be new tools that as this edge
gets pushed and there's more questions
that come up there's new technologies
that are made there's more opportunities
and you talk about this and I love this
point just
you us knowing how to learn being a
metal earner yeah knowing how to learn
so we can keep learning new things as we
keep pushing right right
is that the one of the most important
most first principled things it's
certain yes I think it to levels I mean
I think part of what part of what we are
innovating when engineering evolving as
collectively is our ability to learn
collectively and I would say at this
point in 2019 2020 one of the most
underrated accelerants of that learning
is YouTube mm-hmm
it's just phenomenally accelerating how
fast things learn I was just I mean am I
just talking about like makeup videos or
tutorials I'm talking about doctors
going to YouTube to see how our surgery
is done I'm talking about scientists
going to YouTube to watch someone give a
tech talk on a paper that they wrote so
they can understand it better we're on
this channel someone watching you say
something right and then getting
inspired in their country across the
planet to take initiative in starting a
community around that and absolutely
read them so that's just but that's just
one tiny aspect that's YouTube this is
YouTube of what we're trying to what
what's happening which is that we're
collectively accelerating the rate at
which we learn things and the chief way
that we learn as a species is to the
scientific method method and I wrote one
of the first histories of the scientific
method itself and my point of writing it
was that in the next 50 years the
scientific method is going to change
more than it has the last five hundred
years that the scientific method itself
is evolving and accumulating new
techniques and that science the very
method science itself not just the stuff
that science discovers but the process
of science is also changing which is so
exciting it is because collectively we
are learning how to learn
in more ways and faster and deeper and
the consensus mechanisms are absolutely
and you know foremost among all the
changes that are coming in the
scientific method it's going to be a ice
artificial intelligences always say
plural because there's many different
varieties of them and they are going to
be instrumental in helping us because
our human minds are not general-purpose
intelligence is that's a complete myth
there is no general purpose intelligence
we have very very specific weird
combinations of cognition that we're
evolved for our planet and they're going
to they're probably insufficient to
understand dark matter and dark energy
or to you know to discover how they work
and we're going to need to do a two step
process we're going to invent other
kinds of minds that think differently
than we do to work with us together
collectively to figure these out so so
that's sort of what's in store for it my
only point about that is there is a
collective meta learning that we're
doing but there's also the individual
assignment that we have as individuals
to never learn and that's in my opinion
much further behind in a sense that
we're not even aware of the issues we're
not aware that this is our job that we
need to learn how we learn ourselves or
to optimize our own learning and there's
no curriculum I've seen anywhere in the
world that teaches you or me how to
optimize and understand our own learning
because each of us learned a little
differently for different things and
what we want to be able to arrive at is
is to know fully well how we would best
learn a new language how we would best
learn a new physical skill how we would
best learn a new discipline how many
hours of rest we need between this how
much we have to devote to the practice
we don't know we have no idea and this
is what I think schools should really be
teaching that when you graduate
what you're graduating with is a great
degree in self learning mmm-hmm a degree
in how to optimize your own learning so
that you know yourself the best patterns
and techniques the best way to learn all
the different things in ways that need
to be learned and you know what they are
and you've been practicing you've been
tested and you've been helped by
teachers to optimize your own learning
that is what high school college should
be there's that inner artist to be
unleashed and there are all of these
even from such ancient days of things
like bloom to Sigma just get one-on-one
mentorship and that accelerates you
tremendously all the way up to today's
artificial intelligence is acting as
coaches that have a psychometric profile
and ancestral profile they you've you've
discussed back and forth about what this
this artistic expression is of yours and
there's a tailored daily learning
process of like you said patterns and
techniques around that actualizing that
fullest potential right and actualize it
means they're conveying to you so that
you understand what it is and you can
repeat that and do it again so isn't
that you kind of arrive at doing
something creative that's just the
first-order thing what we want to do is
you want to know what that process was
so that you could do it again even
better than you could and more
importantly in it you can actually
evolve or optimize that process there's
enough self awareness about this that
you can get better at it and that's what
the true Irish you know the Picasso
somebody is that they they sort of
there's a great documentary that there's
a time-lapse of a Picasso working on one
picture as he paints and repaints and
repaint since he painted the same
painting over overnight and as like you
said well that you say well that's
fantastic
and he said well that's fantastic --n
she's changing it again it's like it's
like he's looking for something he's
doing something what's he doing and what
it was was he was aware of what it was
he didn't he's he was trying to some
surprise himself he was trying to get to
something that he hadn't seen before he
he famously said he wasn't interested in
beauty and prettiness and all the places
that we would want to stop with things
that looked pretty or beautiful or cool
and he was not interested in that he was
interested in something that shocked him
it was surprising it was different and
so he he was aware enough of how he
learned and how he did that he could
disappear Ducey's and so if it's not
just like we want to have a mentor to
help us make creative things no no no
whatever mentor that that teaches us
what that process is so that we can
evolve it and make it even better yes
and that is that's a high bar it's a
very very high bar I don't know how to
do that and and maybe it requires a I to
help us do this but I mean I think even
using human teachers we could go a lot
further and that if that was the course
and the courses you graduate
understanding how to optimize your own
learning and so that would be fantastic
yeah that brings the fills me with joy
it fills me with knowing that that is
our highest potential and that it is so
exciting to feel what it feels like when
every single one of us is unleashing the
fullest inner artist right yeah
and you know I like you used to the
artist because in my framework how
artists go about the world and
scientists go but are very very similar
there they're parallel it's the same
topologically it's the same process and
in when you have a space I'm using space
as a in the mathematical sense of a high
dimensional space when you have a space
with as many dimensions as reality has
meaning that there's you know thousands
if not millions of different variables
that are being mapped in that space when
you have a space that's really high
variable and you're trying to navigate
through that you're trying to search
through the space which is what computer
scientists would use as a way of
discovery that you're that when you're
discovering something you're kind of
going through the space looking for some
peak of optimal adaption so they would
they would make a map of success
whatever it is and they were say when
you reach the peak you're at peak and in
the life and and the search is looking
for the optimal you're searching a path
up to the optimal position and that
search that discovery is exactly the
same process when you're inventing
something so when you're inventing
you're doing the same thing you're doing
the same search it looks exactly the
same if you're looking at some insertion
you couldn't tell whether they are
inventing something or discovering
something and that's why I would say you
know it's like did ben franklin and
electricity or discover electricity you
know did someone invent prime numbers
who discovered prime numbers was the
like it was like our language the light
bulb discovered or invented the wheel
they're the same thing it's the same
process and then the artist is the
artist
discovering the painting or inventing
the painting mm-hmm
creating it or discovering it's exactly
the same process those those processes
are basically identical it's really the
same process so an artist who is coming
up with something is often coming up
with it in a very similar process that a
scientist would come up with a new idea
I loved how you also mentioned the not
only with this way of the Ewing
discovery I love that and also the the
way of viewing the rapidly accelerating
mechanisms that are changing of the
scientific method that's very important
as we consensus figure out what is
civilisations collective some knowledge
and how do we find these question marks
at the edge how do we efficiently
galvanize resources there have been some
big pops recently whatever satoshi
nakamoto and blockchain is was a massive
pop in the last ten years now has just
been pushing a very interesting edge
when you're mentioning earlier this
lineage and weird descendants of that
lineage in many ways that is self as a
biological blockchain mm-hmm is there's
a very interesting ways of viewing it
with many orphan chains that have died
out along the way and many again
bifurcations Forks when you said earlier
- so the process of us figuring out how
to you know what is your inner artist is
your inner artist in the seeing the
overlap between biology and the
distributed ledger technologies is your
overlap between brain computer
interfaces
and geopolitics I mean like there's so
many ways to figure out what's actually
at the edge how to make unique
connections at the edge leveraging
artificial intelligence is to run
quadrillions of permutations of all of
these edge pushes to figure out where we
should go how do humans sims have a
symbiosis with that process because is
humanity a biological bootloader for a
digital super intelligence you gave us
this Technium a thousand years from now
we'll roll will we have will we be a a
cut will we be consciousness in the
digital super intelligence and that is
what will exist how do you feel about
that well you have too many questions
there and and I guess maybe just
addressing the last one yeah
I I see the general trends in both
evolution and the Technium is towards
more diversity more mutualism more
specialization so I think it's likely
that we will specie eight I think is for
certain they were gonna make invent
thousands of different species of a eyes
and all the things that we talked about
that were from life consciousness
intelligence
you know self-awareness all those things
are none of those are binary and all of
them are gradations and various so
there's you can have different levels of
life you know a virus has a certain
level of life retirement more we have a
lot of life we're very living because we
have so many different systems life is
not binary some like it's there not
there there was a gradation and there's
various kinds of it same thing with
intelligence and consciousness
consciousness is not binary
it's there it's not there there's many
levels a gorilla has a very interesting
combination of different kind of
consciousness will put consciousness in
machines of various types so there'll be
lots of consciousness around more than
we have now
and intelligence is absolutely the same
with with many varieties many degrees
many Continuum's and gradations of it so
we're going to be surrounded by multiple
varieties of consciousness and
intelligences and life artificial lives
and what's our role is the question that
we're always going to ask and so next
year and the year after 400 years 4000
years we'll still be asking this
question which is where do we fit in
what's what's our role why are we here
what are we good for what can we do that
these other things can't mm-hmm I think
the short term my suspicion is pretty
clear that we are the machines
intelligences we make are much more
aimed towards efficiency productivity
ask answering things narrow
intelligences humans are much more about
asking questions but open-ended stuff
we're very inefficient we'd like to do
inefficient things like art science
those are incredibly inefficient the
only way you can be a good scientist is
if you're wasting time basically at
asking questions getting wrong answer is
having failures it can't be innovated
unless you're going down a dead-end you
can't discover things unless you have a
detour you can't make art efficiently so
we are gonna gravitate to the
inefficiencies at least in the short
term machines oh if it's if it's
concerned with productivity or
efficiency it goes you know goes
productivity is from robots right you
just give it to the AIS and they're
gonna be really good at that if you want
to answer to something you ask a machine
if you want to question you hire
human that's in the beginning but over
the long term you know we'll make
machines ask questions and we'll have to
reevaluate what it is and again if you
believe that humans have the sort of
general purpose intelligence and we're
kind of like they were done but I don't
think we have a general we have a very
peculiar kind of intelligence and our
value will be because we think
differently than the AIS and they eyes
are valued because they think
differently than us and so the one thing
that humans do really well is that we
humans crave the company of other humans
and it's just really really hard to kind
of fake it's hard expensive to fake
another human and it's also usually not
needed because we can make humans so
easily that we are you know we're gonna
seek out our company and the the company
and of a human that's gonna become very
very valuable because we can get all
kind of company we can make virtual
telepresence we can do all kinds of
things very cheaply but to sit like this
it's going to be one of the most
cherished expensive valuable things that
we have and you know someone will take a
plane across the country and come there
and that's that's costly that's
expensive much much cheap to come over
an avatar and we'll do that all the time
but we'll come to value that sitting
there because you can't fake that
there's just fake so many things there
always but what we're really tuned to
that reality we you know we always will
have some value of that and so it may be
that you know our jobs in the future may
be just to keep each other company to
entertain and to enjoy that company
because it's
because we love it yeah the the
neurophysiological effect of the
technologies that we're talking about
when I do see an indistinguishable Kevin
Kelley that's sitting next to me here
and I can't tell you will you will be
able to tell because we took millions of
years of understanding that telling
process and so in a thousand years
though that's a you know this is some
sure sure sure much different than right
under fifty years from now so there's
that and then there's also that I'm very
curious as to the really the process of
self work the process of healing the
process of integrating trauma the
process of marrying science and
spirituality marrying Hollywood in
silicon valley marrying the USA in China
there's so many of these harmonizations
that that we would love to happen that
are part of that architecting process
that you know you listed earlier
thousands of artificial intelligences
well how do we make sure that we have a
deep amount of moral and ethical and
spiritual evolution philosophical wisdom
before we choose to partake in such
potentially we didn't think that we
would unlock the power of the atom and
then hey of oops nuclear bombs and so
where was our where was our spiritual
evolution there where was our where was
the wisdom there to hold back on
something like that so this is still a
big mixing pot of all of those variables
that right yeah well I mean I don't know
I always said the optimistic thing the
way I mean is likewise my optimism is
that yeah we use it twice for a bomb and
we albeit stockpiles still well dip but
we haven't sent them off so so I'll be
it 800 billion dollar per year no it's a
complete USA right it's just real
compliment right it's stupid level of
stupidity but at the same time so far we
learned something so how do we wake up
how do we wake up fully to the this we
were at the very sure sure sure yeah
so that way we ensure that beautiful
world that our hard to know is possible
right yeah how do we well how did you
wake up I mean what was the process many
different paths and I think that's the
answer
yeah I mean I without trying to be live
I think the answer is is an electors of
one thing I think it's everything it's
many different paths it's it's we have
to do everything at once that's always
the problem we can do all these things
at the same time it's not just one thing
and so yeah we want to do all the things
we know we have to do making sure that
there's opportunity spread throughout
the world that you know it's clean water
and energy and clothing education and we
want to have transparencies and we want
to connect everybody we want to when we
have these issues about you know not
everybody is the greatest parent what do
we do about that that's really tough
thing to say how about your path yeah
yeah
you know I was very very fortunate very
blessed very lucky lucky beyond belief I
think luck is
not acknowledged often enough
I mean basically I am lucky I'm where I
am in my view is because I had a lot of
luck for my parents to where I was born
when I was born I was lucky what we want
to do is you want to kind of spread the
surface area of luck so it touches more
people to get them ready to prepare them
for luck when it comes to you know
basically expand the the touch of luck
so and that's what I think civilization
is in some ways is a way in which you
kind of are expanding the surface area
of luck so that luck has potential to
touch more people know they can be ready
for it
and you know so that's so we have that's
another thing that we have to work on
doing at the same time trying to empower
people luck can also be viewed as gifts
it can be viewed as nothing chronicity
is that these gift
basic needs that come up as mirrors in a
sense in the oneness where it does come
up that once I do a deeper amount of
self work myself that all of a sudden my
relationship with my family changes
drastically
mmm with my friends with my inner artist
changes drastically and so it we create
mirrors as we awaken more and more and
right now the internet and especially
social media is a big mirror yeah yeah
and there's a lot of very
crazy reflection that's happening right
now of our subconscious and our both are
our greatest dry for finding the most
signal in the nature of reality and also
be most noise remember inundated our
selves with right so it's such a that's
why when I mentioned perfection earlier
hmm I wonder if literally nothing is
impossible except to make something as
beautiful as this yeah I I think
perfection is such a system possible I
think it's well it's unattainable but
it's also undesirable so I used procopio
earlier I used for topia was this idea
of progressive progress movement towards
something just like I'm and I'm not a I
know there's lots of things that I think
are correct about this kind of news fear
Troodons idea of the of the new sphere
but what I don't agree with his idea
that there's a convergence at this Omega
point that we're coming to a point that
there's some destination that is Tiye
logically predetermined that we're
headed to some end state III think
that's totally wrong what if we learned
the source code of this and then make
another one yeah I think what is I think
there is a they draw our directions I
don't think where's the destiny and
humanity is not about destiny it's about
a direction so we're kind of moving
outward we evolution self-organized
systems are radiating outward from the
Big Bang the original thing with
increasing numbers of diverse solutions
diverse specifics diverse individuals
diverse opportunities
and there's so there's a direction of a
radio outward but there's not some
convergence on to an endpoint so we have
the evolution the world Technium is
moving with directions
there's direction to evolution but
there's not a destiny what is the
directional arrow going towards outward
our life is going to scoring towards
increasing varieties whatever we have
today there will be more varieties
tomorrow and thousand years so even more
varieties is increasing specialization
so the first cell was a general purpose
and over time we made more and more
specialized cells and we made a
general-purpose organism with more and
more specialized in organisms the first
a little bit of intelligence was general
purpose and we have more and more
specific specialized so it goes from the
general to the specific we have a
movement from the simple to the complex
we have the movement from things that
are inert to more mutualistic aliy
dependent so more and more of life
depends on other lives more and more of
our own social interactions or depending
on other people more and more machines
will depend on other machines so we have
increasing towards mutualism we have an
increasing movement towards the
sentience mindful acceleration of the
degrees in which we can adapt and learn
that's called thinking so there's more
and more a general trend towards
increasing levels of learning and
adaption or mindfulness so that those
those are the general trends and
directions yeah beautifully synthesized
I want to also make sure to mention this
because it's a story that that I think
will help unleash the inner artist
out of so many that are in the process
of contemplating beginning or still in
their own process of discovery or maybe
they are already on their path but
they're still struggling somewhat along
the way that the story about putting in
these literally tens of thousands of
hours of time into being your inner
artist in order to become the true best
inner artist you can possibly be with
the pop of the pottery professor story
is yeah it's so incredible yeah yeah you
you you you can have the option to
submit just one or two of your best
pottery creations in for your for your
final score or you literally the
professor will take your collective
weight over all the pottery that you
have made throughout the year and it's
and the best examples of pottery come
from the ones that have literally been
doing the most weight and so this
process of becoming your best inner
artist is so deeply about these tens of
thousands of hours but it's also about
having these really strong metal
learnings that hacks it hacks fast right
like that that I'm here right now with
you uh-huh and you are all menteng my
worldview significantly at the age of
twenty seven plus all these viewers
around the world that are also having
the world yard it's a hack for all of us
because we made this happen right right
and because you were gracious enough to
also catalyze it happening versus if
this didn't happen
we then I wouldn't have gotten this we
would have gotten this kind of hack or
upgrade which I'm going to shave a
couple of those maybe doors right yeah
yeah yeah it's it's it is kind of
remarkable to me to that volume
burrs actually make a difference in the
complexity world we talk about more is
different there is actually something
qualitatively different that happens
when you have more and in the world of
our innovation the the problem is is
that most variations fail right yeah and
so the solution is really literally you
just make enough of n that eventually
you have one that works okay I mean and
that's that's what evolution does it's
sort of stupid it's a stupidest way in
the world I'm doing it you just do it
10,000 times and you and you'll get it
you know you know do it better and so
and that's sort of where we are we we
have to operate in in the real world and
so the the benefit from drawing every
day is that you do it again and again
and you start to and you will do
something a little differently you just
couldn't get to by by yourself I mean
just deliberately doing it and that
moment will take you to the next step
and you do your interviews again and
again and again and that core repetition
so to speak is like a science project
where you do an experiment over and over
again and so that and that solution to
[Music]
innovating and getting somewhere new and
somewhere different somewhere better
comes down to you know numbers like like
you just you do it a lot you do it as a
practice you do it as a discipline you
do it every day because you must and so
that's one of the benefits that we have
of being in this reality this you know
what I think of us are a ride yeah the
ultimate simulation to to your to your
name we have an ultimate simulation
which is like the
the subsidy the the the the quality of
this brief riot we have is this
unbelievable and we tend to squander it
right we that's the fear the fear is
that we'll have this once-in-a-lifetime
opportunity to kind of be immersed in
this thing where and here's here's the
crucial difference you're asking for
about reality the the thing about this
simulation there were in this view this
avatar is that we actually in this
arrangement of things we have the
ability to have an impact on others and
we have this very very complicated
system where I actually can do something
that could affect somebody way far away
who doesn't know me I mean I can do
things that you have it could affect
millions of people I can do things that
can affect people for good I have this
power to impact by being in this body
that has physical restraints and all
kinds of things and senses but that body
this presence this this reality is one
that's served built to kind of optimize
our ability to have impact on each other
we can imagine most of other realities
and we'll make many of them the a our
world and VR and and we can do amazing
things in them we'll be able to do
certain things will have some impact
we'll be able to have some senses but
we're not going to have the the belt in
leverage that we have in this world here
and so you know the the lament from
Christmas story Charles Dickens story
the lament of of the Scrooge is that he
realized that he wasn't using that life
for impact when he had the chance
mmm and it wasn't that
listen so much are you gonna miss the
fresh mangoes and the hair blowing
through your and all these others say
yes that's part of it but the thing was
is that he realized that he could have
actually influenced people's lives back
then but he missed that opportunity and
so we have in this situation here been
set up in some weird way to optimize our
potential ability to impact each other
that we aren't going to be able to
replicate for a very long time we can we
can replicate lots of aspects of reality
but this one of being able to actually
have the impact in so many different
dimensions is missing and will be
missing for a long time Wow there are
still so many ways to go one of the
things that I I do want to bring up is
that there is a popular video right now
on the web and it's leave several years
old you showed it during your talk I
forget what that was believed it was the
the Japanese oh oh the hyper reality the
hyper reality yeah yeah
where we are we are wearing our
augmented reality technologies and the
entire world has added there's a digital
layer that's added on to our world that
is that has you know very much so like
lots of good lots of bad right all there
and so one of the things about hyper
realities that I'm interested to to ask
you about is that there seems to be a
way of viewing hyper realities like
something as fundamental as like a Santa
Claus that
is some sort of a something that's not
true that we tell children and then they
believe it's true
and that makes a hyper reality where
they believe something's true okay when
it's not well yeah so a lot of our
fictional characters are like that like
Superman has a certain level of reality
as a concept I mean it's like that that
archetype that hypothetical mythical
some mythical character has some level
of reality in our minds because it we
can share we can share there's something
that we can share there are certain
attributes that we would agree on
there's you know as a concept it has a
reality even though I mean not real
may not be real and physical realm it
has other levels or spheres of reality
ideas are real so so Santa Claus is like
that it's a mythical character that has
some level of reality and and that's a
very basic level right point though in
the grand thing which was that you
mentioned this at the beginning of what
this whole idea of the atom and us
buying into what atoms are all here and
that the cells look and function of it
but it's a big way and that that the the
galaxies in the universe function in a
very specific way
and so then when I look at a molecule of
water and you look at that molecule of
water can we collectively agree that the
molecule of water looks the same because
well yeah these are the ways that maybe
the scientific consensus mechanism could
hopefully upgrade itself in a sense
where there there could be something
that is like a sort of base camp or
catalogue of what we collect
we believe is objective yes yes yes so
again I think science is operating with
that you know it's still very it's a
contingent it's a it's you know it's
contingent consensus but I I think we're
on a process now with kind of Google and
some of the AI so actually generate a
corpus of statements or knowledge that
is graphed that has connected together
that we would come to accept in the
consensus way that was true so it would
have a statement saying that you know
London is the capital of England and
most everything else in that corpus
would agree with that and therefore it
has you know 99.9% agreement and
therefore we can say well that's true so
there is a consensus and consensus works
I'm not sure you know we were thinking
about this this idea of the virtual
reality is an alternative versions of
thing the hyper hyper reality is where
that can be a slight issue when we have
right a planet that is spherical that
still people say is computer-generated
imagery but when the space photos are
released and so there's a hyper reality
happening where it's there's a there's a
scientific consensus that is aiming to
be made around spherical planet or star
moon orbiting that and then there's a
body of people that say that no flat
earth or no lie and so we have in a
sense a sense making mechanism but that
is deeply a part of this push that we've
been talking about through the
conversation that will will me that may
need these first principles like you are
describing where there are these
statements that hopefully you know
children being born into the
world can can enjoy the statement like
the planet orbits the star and that the
breath I take in comes from
phytoplankton and yeah yeah I I I think
that's mostly there I mean I think you
know I'm not there's lots of issues with
this kind of fake news and conspiracy
stuff I'm not as concerned about the
Flat Earth people that's just almost to
me almost like a performance art I don't
really take it very seriously but I
there are other issues like climate
change where we're arriving at a
consensus is much more important and
much interest is more difficult and I
think you know as we go forward we can
enter into certain things like race and
genetics where there is going to be a
lot of contention about what is the
consensus and what is actually true and
in part because a we don't know and to
the process of finding out is
uncomfortable yes and so and so and and
and I can imagine other things as we go
forward where we might have difficulty
arriving at consensus and there may be
kind of differences of program ethics
into artificial intelligences or integer
navigation right weight or like whether
you know whether it if if an AI
shouldn't one time say I have a soul mmm
and then there'll be questions about
whether to accept that or not do you
believe that or not what's the evidence
and so you hold the whole the whole
issues of unconsciousness and how we
would define here to even verify it so I
think I so so I think there will be
issues that we may not even know where
we stand on right now they were going to
come in the future but I do but I think
in general we are moving to a place and
again the thing about the thing about
these truth things is that they're
brought in
only if they can be connected to
everything else and then they become
useful and the problem with lots of
things that aren't true is they're not
useful I mean one of the things about
evolution in terms like the evolution
debate with the creationist is that the
thing about evolution is as incredibly
useful it's with evolution the Old Earth
the idea of geology and layers that's
how you find oil right I mean that that
knowledge is used to determine where we
find oil is there's a use to it creation
science is completely useless it tells
you nothing there's no predictions
there's it's it's you know it's by its
nature the utilitarian right of truth is
so powerful yeah okay and so what went
when you can bring it in and connect it
everything else it increases its values
so like other things things have values
by how much they're connected data alone
is never valuable data that only becomes
valuable when it's connected to other
data at the structuring of it right and
so and so that's the so the problem
that's the problem is like it's up to me
it's a self terminating self limiting
problem about these untruthfulness
because ultimately they were just proven
not to be useful they can be distracting
and causing problems but they're gonna
disappear eventually because I simply
aren't useful enough in the long term
yeah the short term that can cause a lot
of problems yes and there you've used
this and we use it several times species
amnesia is a big thing where we don't
yet know so much maybe even as high as
99% of all the archeological excavations
have yet to still be found around the
planet and here we sit with this clock
ticking of them disappearing and so in
order for us to understand that or in
order for us to understand something as
where one person may use this word
conspiracy people still want to
investigate into something as recent as
under 20 years ago
the 911 people still want to invest in
and understand what is really the truth
of that or that even as recent as just a
couple months ago with Jeffrey Epstein
right right similarly right people want
to know what is the truth
right who if any are real true
puppeteers sure we're moving knobs right
because when we had Cambridge Cambridge
analytic people want to know the truth
behind it what whoever's behind it and
so so that that that that interest is
not just on the right it's on the left
as well it's everywhere people
understand that there are big dynamic
systems that the elites the powerful
have mota have motives to shape the
world so it's a very natural question I
think the it's a natural question to ask
but the difference would be what do you
accept as as if it's our proof what's
what's your criteria and here's the
thing in this new world that we're in
and that is is that it's almost
impossible in today's media to ascertain
the truth of anything in real time by
the evidence of itself and so if you
look in a photograph or text you can't
tell whether that's been altered if
someone sends you a mess he said this
well anybody could change those letters
and you could just make up something how
would I know they really said that well
here's a photograph do I believe it well
anybody can Photoshop it and here's a
video well anybody can make a deep faith
these days I can't believe that the only
thing you can believe is the source and
the source is only believable in terms
of their history of how reliable they've
been in the past or if they have an
umbrella or if they've been bedded by
someone else who's reliable like
newspaper or something and so we're
coming down to the basically to the
point where you can't tell right away in
real time whether something believable
but all you can believe is their source
mm-hmm and so that's sort of where we
are and part of what we want to do is
make a system where the sources of
things are embedded into the things so
they can't be taken apart so that you
can always do you'll be able to say well
where did this come from because that's
really the only thing that we can
ascertain in real time
eventually we'll figure out but in real
time we can only evaluate by the source
full circle because the same thing
applies to this reality
it all goes back to source right it's so
beautiful right very last question sure
what is most beautiful what is most
beautiful
[Music]
I think for me I think the most
beautiful things are acts of
selflessness of in some ways a generous
surrendering of one's own interest for
the benefit of others that kind of a
kind of almost unreasonable help it to
me is this the most beautiful thing in
the world someone who you know by every
logic should not diminish their
opportunities for the benefits someone
else that's to me is beautiful and
speaks to that inefficiencies right
exactly right it's it's you know it's
not rational it's not efficient
it's stravagant it's generous it's
surprising it's art it's beautiful
yes which in the long run may actually
end up being part of the efficiency no
it's it's part of opportunity the
expansion of choices it's which itself I
mean so the thing about it is at the
universe part of the whole the universe
is totally inefficient right it's it's
universes it's the most extravagant
irrational could paradoxical say the
same thing and call it inefficient
symphony
right it's it's it's it's just it's
non-mechanical it's it's irrational it's
it's the most beautiful thing because it
is an act of it's a gift it's an act of
selfless yes right I mean the universe
as a whole because there's because
there's really no reason for it in a
sense of accomplishing an efficiency an
efficiency right versus a symphonic
expression right as a gift as a gift
right yeah so so so you can almost
reduce my my my response to saying is a
gift is the most beautiful thing Wow Wow
Kevin thank you thank you yeah thank you
you're really welcome enjoy the
conversation it was surprising and a
gift to me this has been a huge gift to
us thank you for coming on shore Graham
thanks everyone for tuning in we greatly
appreciate it we'd love to hear your
thoughts in the comments below in the
episode let us into thinking about all
these topics that Kevin was talking
about on the program we'd love to hear
your thoughts have more conversation
with your friends families co-workers
people online about these subjects that
were discussed get catalyzing these stop
provoking conversations around our world
check out the links in the bio below
again that's both KK org as well as
Kevin's other profile links in the bio
below check those out go follow him will
support his books go check that out and
also support the artists the
entrepreneurs the spiritual leaders in
around the world and in your community
support them and help them grow you can
find stimulation all of our links to our
Shore below a PayPal patreon
cryptocurrency do support us and help us
continue flourishing and go and build
the future manifest your dreams into the
world we love you very much everyone
thank you for tuning in and we will see
you
great okay Wow
good yeah that was a great first round
[Music]